you wake up tomorrow morning and you're
on the street and you have nothing you
don't have a single contact in your
network all you have is the knowledge
and experience that you've had
throughout your career how do you build
up from there if I had to do it again I
go work for McDonald's and the reason I
go work from McDonald's you know whether
it's seven bucks an hour or 15. I don't
really care they have the best Business
Systems in the world so right inside
little McDonald's you can learn
everything you need to learn about
business except for the management side
I spend most of my time with
entrepreneurs I don't spend my time with
people who complain about the economy so
nothing really changed I just go back to
being an entrepreneur entrepreneurs have
one thing in common they keep going
they'll change the rules they'll
reinvent the rules you know they don't
just take one answer so a real
entrepreneur it really makes no
difference which country you're in you
know I have a friend from France he
started buying vineyards in Napa and
Sonoma so he went back to the French
government and says I want to ship my
wine in bulk to California and the
government says you can't do that he
says okay I can't ship them in barrels a
guy goes yeah he says okay I'll ship it
in bottles but he's still figuring out
how to do it his wine with his
California wine and all this and so he
went back to the French conference here
try this see if it's not better and so
now they're all confused because he
didn't break any rules so I'll say it
again entrepreneur is a mindset first a
skill set and rules hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggled to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's learn how to
master wealth with Robert Kiyosaki and
his 10 rules for financial success enjoy
yeah
I am very shy
very very shy
and I came back from Vietnam and I could
kill people but I couldn't talk to
people
and one day I said to my wife decided to
follow my rich dad's footsteps and just
said to him I want to be an entrepreneur
he says you got one problem I said
what's that I said you're shy
I said what's wrong with being shot he
says you got to sell you gotta handle
rejection
number one skill can you handle
S no I couldn't handle it so I still
don't want to learn how to sell
so without this is a 1973 I was 25 years
old
and my Rich Dad said How's your love
life
so it sucks
so you're getting late I said no
he says because you can't sell
guys got it
so when I talk about what skill do you
need
when the ship hits the fan you better
start selling so I went to work with
Xerox in 1974 so I can learn how to sell
took me four years and I was number one
okay and today I'm a best-selling author
you know most phds tell me I can't right
yes I said I can't right but I can't
sell
if you can't sell you don't make money
period
end the statement
you know just because you have a product
doesn't mean Jack
but the important thing is you start
you know I don't care what product you
start with but you start
and I started off with nylon wallets
success wiped me out
you know we couldn't sell couldn't sell
also they took off then I couldn't
Finance I couldn't Finance couldn't
Finance because the sales kept going
through the roof now
trouble is I kept borrowing and I
couldn't sustain the sales
next lesson
but that's how we learn
okay because I'm one of those kids who
don't like school
you know school is good
for people who like school
but here was my poor dad head of
Education PhD on the governor's Board of
Hawaii and all this stuff and his kid me
and I'm flunking out of school because I
can't read I can't write I said I
couldn't read I couldn't write I was
bored out of my mind you know I was just
hey
so what I did instead
was that's when I met my Rich Dad it was
my best friend's father and he used
these things called a game
see games are the best teaching tools
see when I'm playing this game this is
how the rich taught their kids battle
strategy is called chess
my rich dad taught me to be a rich man
playing Monopoly we played Monopoly hour
after hour after hour
you know the formula for great wealth
and monopolies for greenhouses one red
Hotel
so today in Arizona I own 8 000 Green
Hotel I mean greenhouses
and several red hotels I just played
Monopoly for real
so that's the power of a game because a
game engages me mentally
physically because I accidentally
emotionally because when somebody knocks
me out
oh
I better wake up you know I made a
mistake
and spiritually because it's spirit that
wins now if you just saw a Golden State
play then
play there
you know everybody's I mean I love
LeBron James I love Cleveland you know
but one guy cannot take on a team
and I think LeBron scored 60 of all the
points in assists and all that but a
better team beatle
so when you look at business business is
the same thing
but this is a team sport I have to have
good accountants Good attorneys good
marketing guys good Tech Guys
great staff have to have great leaders
you know
the trouble with most entrepreneurs are
self-employed
so they quit their job
and you know in America today the SBA
the small business administration says
there's 28 million
small business owners 28 million
24 million are classified as
non-employers
their one-man team
you know they like this guy said okay
I'm going to take you on
are you crazy but that's what most
entrepreneurs are trying to do
because that's what they're taught to do
in school to be the rugged individual
you know in school I was very successful
as long as I could cooperate at test
time
but in school cooperation at test time
is called cheating
in the real world the guys have the
biggest team win
so all I focus on is putting the best
team together
meanwhile a lot of times the a students
in school that the doctors and lawyers
are sitting there all by themselves
they're sitting ducks but they're
entrepreneurs
is this a mindset tactics strategy I
went to military school I'm a former
Marine so I think like a military
operation which I love chess
so most most entrepreneurs you know they
have this job okay I'm going to be an
entrepreneur in this case is Massacre
that's very good because they went to
school they learned to get a job and
they take tests on their own they have
to be the smartest
that's like the LeBron James
I don't want to be the smartest guy in
my team but I want to have the best team
and that's why I win most of my games
it's great I think like this and the
doctor's sick like this yeah I got you
man for some reason I get the sense I'm
going to win
this video I'm
free work
s for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there so the other thing with when
people say live below your means
yeah
you don't like to live below your means
do you no no
and I think when you say to somebody
live below your means you wipe the
spirit out it's like saying somebody if
you want to lose weight go on a
starvation diet it doesn't make you
healthier to starve yourself
so I would rather get financially
educated that's why I read read your
books because I want to this is my
greatest asset I want to feed my brain
so that I can expand my means without
getting into excessive debt or where I
start to lose because death it could say
is a 2 8 sword but telling somebody to
live below your means
is almost inhumane I never felt good
doing it I wanted to strive to do better
every day I want to do better every day
I like the good life like I tell the
story of
taxing underneath your jet you know I
was in my jet but it was a little
lyricette I look up and there's a 727 a
Night taxi under it I said
holy man you know it's it's big boys and
their toys but nonetheless it inspired
me I said okay I'm in a Learjet now it's
time to step up and it doesn't mean the
jet will make me happier what makes me
happier is the wanting to get better to
get smarter to do better if you did not
have the rich dad in your life what
would you be doing today
that's hard to say if I didn't have my
rich dad because um
as a young kid starting at probably
about the age of five six seven eight
nine
I really wanted to be rich
so I think number one is desire
you know and then you naturally seek
Your Role Models and teachers and in my
lifetime I've had multiple Rich dads you
know my rich dad was my best friend's
father starting the age of nine
and then today I still seek mentors and
wise men and Wise Women
because that's how you get wiser is by
hanging out with smart people everyone
says finding good real estate is hard
when you're getting started
what's the value of good Network and
good Partnerships
well I'll say it again in 1973 I came
back from Vietnam
and I was a pilot out there
and I took a real estate course it was
385 dollars
three days long
and that was a lot of money back that I
was only making five hundred dollars a
month so 385 was all I had
and the instructor at the end of the
program said to me he said order the
whole class of about 30 of us he says
your education begins now that you leave
the class
you don't get educated while the class
so his assignment was that everybody or
30 of us with the parent team will get
up in teams two or three to the team and
we had to look at 100 properties in 90
days
and he says don't buy anything just look
at 100 properties do the evaluation of
each property right up write a short
blurb about it why it's good why it's
bad
and it's at the end of 90 days and 100
properties then you make up your mind if
you're going to buy something
he says if you haven't found a one
property in 100 100 deals you start
again you know you start again another
100.
and that's what most that's why most
people are not rich is they're not
willing to go through that process
of looking at a hundred deals to find
one deal and this sometimes in you and I
know you look at a lot of frogs to find
one princess
you know but when you find that one
princess everybody goes oh well how do
you get so lucky well I looked at a lot
of dirt dirt dogs out there you know and
that's like anything in life you don't
marry the first man or woman you meet
hopefully you kiss a couple of them you
know before you do my last paycheck I
still remember it clearly
he was one of the worst and the best
days of my life and I was in Puerto Rico
I wasn't I was working for Xerox
and my boss gave me my last it wasn't a
paycheck was a bonus check I think it
was about 30 000 bucks taxable it's the
only problem with that so I got this
check and I went holy Mack
erel you know I mean so I was excited
but I was also Disturbed
and so this other guy comes up to me his
name was John and John says to me he
says you're going to be back I said why
he says because you're going to fail I
looked at him and said look
a few expletive words
because that's what he did he left Xerox
failed and he came back
I said look
you fail and you come came back but I'm
going to fail and I'm never coming back
and that's the attitude do you know what
I mean if if you say well if I fail I'll
go back to Mommy and Daddy then that's
what you'll do so if you fail that's
when I became an entrepreneur because I
had no money I had no money for years
yeah I didn't have a paycheck but that's
what my Rich Dad encouraged me to do is
when you're when you don't have this
paycheck you get hungrier smarter and
it's a test of your character will you
become a crook we become dishonest will
you cheat and steal or will you become a
better human being
so really that's the benefit of becoming
an entrepreneur as you really find out
who you are when you don't have anything
if you're an entrepreneur and you're
going to be a big entrepreneur
leadership skills and communication
skills are more important than a law
degree
so now I have another book that just
came out it's called the eight lessons
in military leadership
and the military I went to Military
Academy and all that you know from day
one you're learning leadership
you know day one at the Academy I have
to stand in front of 2018 year old kids
and go Section 10 Hut and that's where
they're going to say true you you know
so that's when you learn to be a leader
now as you said to me when we first met
the trouble with the military got a
little rough
so I had a hard time when I came back
from Vietnam and I went to work for
Xerox and you know people don't like the
idea to call them an and a
you know stuff like that yeah
the word is a curse word in a minute
yeah hey you're not doing this
you know but they don't I'm gonna call
my HR person
I better make some changes here you know
what I'm talking about of course you
can't talk straight no in Corporate
America military you can it's it's you
have to yeah yeah and they love it yeah
you know once you get promotions if
you're doing them well when I got called
names I said oh the guy likes me
so that's why I follow you guys with
military veterans you know you have
probably the number one skill to be an
entrepreneur which is leadership the
ability to listen to not take it
personally and kill still get the job
done it is the best training in the
world you know
the saddest thing about leaving the
military was leaving the guys behind
there there were some of the best in the
world and there were you know they
weren't all college graduates they were
just my Gunners my mechanics you know
all this stuff camaraderie's oh Jesus
priceless priceless and so all I did
when I when I started the Rich Dad
company was to have that same sense of
teamwork inside Richton that's why
there's no ranks and all this stuff in
this company everybody gets to say what
they want to say people are free to do
what they want I stay out of their way
and we got the job done so the Midas
touch is five things you got to be a
must remember number one is the thumb
which is strength of character you fail
stand up don't lie don't cheat don't
just stand up own it keep going on
strength this is focus you know the
index finger this is where I'm going and
I talk about how I went to flight
schools you know preparing to fly in
Vietnam you know people are shooting at
you still got to stay focused on your
target even if you're getting killed in
the process that's what everybody knows
this is what you stand for you know so
Donald stands for the the absolute
wealth and what I stand for is very
simple Financial education keep it
simple you know teach people to manage
their money so I stand for that and I
don't ever get off that track the ring
fingers for relationships if you if
somebody is struggling financially to be
at a company a country or marriage it's
because you have a bad relationship the
thing that Donald and I always say is
that you can't do a good deal with a bad
partner and God knows I've had some bad
partners
and they're just incompetent but they
want to pretend they're smart and then
the little one is a little finger every
entrepreneur must do something that
nobody else does for example in the
United States Walmart their whole system
of business is designed to give you the
lowest price possible everything whereas
Little Mom and Pop store they'll say
well I'm gonna put things on sale that's
not the same thing FedEx says overnight
that was their whole thing they built
the whole company around that little
promise uh Domino's Pizza in America was
pizza in less than 30 minutes so the
entire business was built around one
simple little promise and those are the
things that make entrepreneurs extremely
rich or extremely poor if they don't
have almost five is there a time to bail
out on a project though I mean when I
don't that's not in my vocabulary yeah
look
I have a I have an unfair Advantage you
know I went to war
and a war I'm alive because other guys
died for me when you see stuff like that
you know how can I quit
most guys are just wimps cowards
they don't have it
so they should they should get a job
very important diagram my rich dad
showed me when I was a little boy was a
diagram known as a cash flow quadrant
and the quadrant is made up of the four
different people who make up the world
of business so my Rich Dad said in the
world of business there's ease and E's
stand for employees an employee he says
you can always tell who they are by
their core values and what they employ
whether the president or the janitor of
the company will always say the same
words the words are I'm looking for a
safe secure job with benefits that's
what makes them an employee because
their core values are security
the other other one of the four is the s
or the small business owner or the
self-employed and again their core
values will cause them to use the same
words which are if you want it done
right do it by yourself s means they're
also solo the generally one person act
or they'll operate by themselves
on the right side of the quadrant are
the B's and what Rich Dad said the Beast
stood for was big business or like Bill
Gates Forbes defines big businesses 500
employees or more and their words are
different they say I'm looking for a
good system a good Network and the
smartest people I know to help run my
business so that they're unlike the S
they don't want to run the company by
themselves they want smart people to run
their companies for them
and then the fourth of the quadrant is
the I and I stands for investor these
are people who have money work hard for
them these people are people have people
work hard for them and these are the
people that work hard for the rich here
and the thing of note here is that most
people who go to school are programmed
for the E and the S side for example was
my poor dad
who always said to me son go to school
so you can get a nice safe secure a job
and So my poor dad wanted me to be an
employee
and since the time I was a kid get a
safe secure job study paycheck and
benefits okay
I didn't want to be an employee and I
said Mama and Mom and Dad I want to be a
rich man and I fight with my dad so my
mother finally said Son
if you want to be rich my mother was
registered nurse and she said you want
to be rich the richest people I know are
doctors so my mom wanted me to come over
here be a specialist a small business
person I said it's only one problem with
that Mom doctors are really smart and
she says you got a good point there not
going to be a doctor so I you know so I
went to school I have a Bachelor of
Science degree I can drive ships and I
can fly planes I flew for the Marine
Corps but that I've never used any of
that education because I wanted to
become a business owner so it was my
rich dad who basically said to me you
know become a business owner and learn
to be a professional investor
so one of the big differences here
between these people is that
is called taxes in 1943 the U.S the
federal government passed a law that
said employees had to pay tax before
they got paid so when you go to you when
you get your paycheck from your employer
you open it up and voila the
government's always taken a sizable
chunk of it and the harder you work and
the more money you make the more money
they take from you so that's why it's
not that good to be an employee because
you can never get ahead because the more
you work more money you make the greater
they pay in taxes
now that the doctors and lawyers and
attorneys you know accountants were all
laughing so these guys they got you know
their game paying a lot of taxes so
naturally
the federal government changed the laws
again so in 1986 the U.S I think called
86 tax reform act and it basically
basically took a lot of the benefits
away from people who are self-employed
small business doctors and lawyers so
today in America unfortunately these
guys pay the highest percentage in taxes
it is tragic and a lot of people think
they're investors but what they're
really doing is they're just giving
their money to people like mutual funds
companies and all that so they're not
they're investing but they're not really
investors see the big tax breaks are on
this side you know the laws are pretty
tight here but this area is very very
great
so by being a business owner on the
right hand side of the quadrant you can
make a lot more money and pay a smaller
percentage of taxes legally and the key
word is legally in the investor quadrant
it is possible to make millions of
dollars and pay zero percent taxes
legally and so it was my rich dad who
said to me says you know Robert if you
really want to be rich learn to build
businesses it made more sense to him to
work hard to build a business something
you owned and something you'd pass on
for Generation to generation to your
kids whereas My Poor Dad said work hard
but my Rich Dad said why would you work
hard for something you'll never own and
you can get fired from right away again
that was a difference in values so my
Rich Dad suggested I learned how to be a
business owner and learn how to be an
investor and that's one of the big
differences on this side of the quadrant
these people here work for security they
work for money also on this side over
here their key value that they want is
they want
Freedom they don't want to have to work
at a job anymore they don't want to have
to work for the rest of their lives one
of the beauties of business for the 21st
century it allows people to make the
transition of the E and the S side to
the B side especially
and so you can become a big business
owner and the difference between an S
and A B small business and big business
is most of these guys can't quit working
most small business owners if they stop
working for more than a month the
business collapses you know they don't
really have a business most of these
people own a job
so the beauty of business for the 21st
century it allows these people to make
the transition to the B side so that you
don't have to keep working hard for
money and the money can actually come in
passively then once you have your
business up and running then I always
recommend
you then begin investing with your
excess cash paying less and less in
taxes and that's the reason the rich are
getting richer because you made it this
far
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to get rich in network
marketing with Robert Kiyosaki check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there let me tell you why I
endorse network marketing or why I call
it the power of it the reason for it is
as a as an entrepreneur
this word here network marketing